coach thanks for calling in i appreciate
it hi suzie how are you
oh i'm great i'm great i'm sitting here
i probably won't go home i think i
locked rich in the basement
because i just needed to get out of my
house but there's nothing wrong with
that right
steve the guys were asking me the guys
were asking me about what was the best
line rich used when we were dating back
in the day
i refrained to answer that because i'd
like to keep my marriage going strong
but what did you use when you met margot
what did you say to her what was your
best line what was your game
oh i had no games um it's a miracle that
i even
was able to to pull it off i actually
called her
by the wrong last name on our first date
i thought her last name was brenner it
was it was brennan
and so i got off to a really slow start
i was going to say you're lucky that you
had a second date after that
right i am i'm very lucky that that
happened but uh
yeah i was i was not you know i didn't
have i didn't have a lot of game i
didn't have a lot of lines in my
in my arsenal so um you know i just i
think i mentioned something
about hey have you seen my three-point
percentage you know
something like that you didn't say you
didn't say have you seen my dunking
ability
nothing like that definitely did not say
that
so there were no anthony edward style
dunks in your repertoire back then i
take it maybe now
or or i don't know ever i might have
been on the receiving end
of a couple of those but uh yeah
definitely definitely not
not anthony no there it was pretty
pretty to watch we watched in the last
segment also his sound bite when he was
uh being interviewed by the irish i
don't know if you saw him being
interviewed by an irish correspondent
that kid anthony edwards is he he
stopped him he said i need you to say it
again i was just busy looking at his
accent and he's a perfect example
of just an incredibly great young rookie
um that's just so much fun to watch i'm
curious about what it's like for you
with rookies these days because you have
so many now
and you're bringing in so many young
players how if rookies changed over the
years that you've been involved with the
nba
well i think the biggest thing susie is
that they're coming into the league
at such a young age now that um
their the learning curve is just
enormous whereas when i first got into
the league most of the
most of the rookies had played in
college for several years that had
you know played for a college coach who
you know really helped him prepare for
the league and so yeah
i think 20 30 years ago
rookies were generally more prepared to
to make an impact right away and and
these days they're getting that
education once they get to the league
and
that's why the league has done a good
job you know trying to
build the g league and find ways to
you know help player development but all
these guys are coming in
just so green and so wrong this is the
best league in the world obviously so
it's uh
there's just a huge uh learning curve
ahead of them when they arrive
and then the whole key is you know how
quickly can they get up to speed with
everything that's happening in front of
them
and what are you doing steve kerr to
help them do such what's your technique
in terms of coaching obviously
it's working as the warriors come off
and win last night
well we are our rookie this year uh as
james wiseman
um unbelievably talented young guy um
incredibly poised and mature for for
someone who's 19 and
only played three college games at
memphis because of
uh you know ncaa rules that that
uh that made him ineligible so
um with james you know the the one of
the big changes in the league now is
that you have
much bigger coaching steps so we have we
have 12 people in our coaching staff
which allows us to devote
individual coaches to every single guy
on the team
and so we we have a couple of coaches
who work every day with james
uh watch film with them who get on the
floor uh on an individual level and then
of course we have our our team practices
as well
but it really is kind of a crash course
you're just trying to
you know give give him everything
possible but but not overload him you
know that's the that's the trick you got
to find that balance between
overwhelming a young guy and um you know
helping him along with all the
information that he needs
what's it been like for you coaching
during this pandemic
um it's
it's different it's uh you know we have
since i've been here you know it's my
seventh year coaching the warriors and
one of our one of our big principals
that we talk about all the time is joy
you know we just feel like
this is uh such a privilege to to play
basketball for a living to coach
basketball for a living you know we're
we're in some of the best years of our
lives as a group so
you know let's enjoy it let's let's get
the most out of this and
you know we also want to work and
compete and and and that so it's all
part of it but
the hardest part during the pandemic is
to achieve
joy because the world is suffering and
families are suffering and
and um so whereas in the past it's
always been really
easy to to bring a lot of joy to
practice every day and to
you know do things on the road you know
whether it's
team meals or everybody going out
bowling or or
you know to a movie just you know team
organized
events that can kind of bring the group
together and give everybody a chance to
have fun
can't do any of that now and so it's
very
difficult to lighten the atmosphere
during a
during a global pandemic when there are
no no fans in the stands but
um you know that's what we we try to do
anyway we try to achieve
you know some some levity and and give
the guys a chance to
to really look forward to something
during their day uh meaning
you know coming into the gym and seeing
everybody and getting some work in
and i would imagine that you lean that
much harder on draymond green
and on steph curry to provide that kind
of mentorship to the younger guys as
they come along
because you have limited opportunity to
be off the court with them
yeah no doubt no doubt and and you know
every team is different
the way uh it's constructed and
and this team is
probably has the fewest number of uh
vets that any of any coach that i've uh
or any team that i've coached
i guess last year was similar so the
last two years you know we just haven't
had a ton of vets
whereas you know the first few years we
had so many guys who were
mentoring young players you know guys
like andre iguodala david west
bowser pachulia so now we have a much
more
much younger team much more
inexperienced team and so draymond and
stuff
are really carrying the load um
in terms of trying to lead and guide and
get these guys
where we need to go before i move on
from the warriors uh steve kerr here on
the rich eisen show i'm susie schuster
and for rich
how is clay thompson doing any update on
him
clay's doing great he's uh he's on our
road trip that we just returned from
last night and
and uh first trip he's been on and he he
was just great he's got such a good
sense of humor and everybody
so happy to see him and
his rehab is right on schedule you know
he's he's i think
probably two and a half months post
surgery
so he's uh he's out of the boot you know
he's able to
get in the pool you know i get on an
underwater treadmill that kind of stuff
uh he's doing therapy treatment every
day
but it's just a matter of time with with
an achilles injury it's just
you know it's going to be it's going to
be a while before he's on the court but
he's really
is really progressing in a good mood
susie schuster here in for rich eisen on
the rich eisen show with coach steve
kerr
what's your thoughts on the last dance i
i i guess i talked to you but i never
talked to you about
that in particular i'm curious to hear
what you thought about how that
documentary ended out
well it was really fun for one thing i
watched it with my my
kids you know who are all in their you
know mid-20s now
pretty much so uh it was fun for them
because they were
alive but uh didn't didn't know what was
happening in 1998
so kind of fun to watch with them and
and for them to get a glimpse of what
what our our life was like back then um
i think the they did a great job with
the documentary they captured things
really well the
the hard part was not seeing
uh some guys who really made a huge
impact on our team
because they can only cover so much in a
documentary
but guys like ron harper uh luke longley
were really really big uh pieces and big
people
on our team and and um we didn't get
much
info on them um and and i i was
disappointed for them just because it
really is
yeah it's a nice thing for all of us to
be able to look back on um
you know as teammates uh you know 23
years later
and i wish there had been a little bit
more on those guys i thought that was
surprising too
because when i covered the lakers and
ron was there i saw how close he was
with phil jackson
so i was actually shocked that he didn't
play a bigger role there
yeah i mean one of the reasons phil
brought ron to l.a
to the lakers was because of the impact
he made
on the bulls and uh and ron was yeah he
was kind of the
the uh the other attack dog in our
defense
um you know that's what our our uh
coaches used to call our
our our defense the dobermans you know
they do scotty michael
dennis ron harper i mean those guys were
they were just a wrecking machine
um they could they were all just long
and athletic and strong and they could
switch and
guard anybody on the floor really uh
kind of a modern defense you know but it
was one of the first
versatile defenses the kind of thing you
see now like that that we've had for
example with the warriors
you know with guys like iguodala and
green and klay thompson
durant you know all these long active
ranging defenders and
at one time on the court balls were in
my mind were really
one of the first teams to ever uh
present that kind of defense to and up
to an opponent and uh so harp was a huge
part of that
and uh yeah so
i think all of us you know as we called
each other and you know
staying in touch with guys we we all
sort of had the same sentiment that
man this is great but uh too bad harp
and
and uh luke longley aren't more um
involved with this because they like i
said they they played
played huge roles i have to ask then
what was the conversation like with
michael j with michael jordan
after the he punched me i punched him
segment that aired on the last dance
well we have not spoken since since the
last dance came out i haven't talked to
him probably in a year or so
um just because that's you know it's
kind of the
the routine you know when maybe we see
each other and in charlotte
you know when the warriors play there or
maybe at a golf tournament or something
but
um you know so we haven't we haven't
really talked but
um at the time um
when all that stuff was going on that
was just uh
it was a big part and i think the uh i
think the documentary covered a little
bit a big part of playing for the bulls
was you had to
you had to stand up to michael's uh
presence
and uh intimidation you know it was just
part of the way he tested everybody and
um
and you know if you if you stood up to
it you were good so that's basically
what happened with us
you know he he pressed me and i stood up
to it and we were
we were good after that and uh he
trusted me after that
so kind of uh you know an indoctrination
i guess
and michael said that he felt bad after
that and i'm curious i wonder if in a
way
that gelled your relationship could that
have been
the impetus to turning that around you
said you know that he reached out to you
afterwards
phil's phil has gone on the record
saying that he felt bad about it you
felt
you had to stand up to him so in a way
it could have been a turning point oh
for sure
for sure um and that's i think that's
the
the the thing that's
really maybe the the most uh unique
thing about
uh that team and about michael's
leadership style was
uh that you know there you either
you either passed the test or you did
you know he he put a lot of pressure on
people
and and it was not light and enjoyable
you know every day
we practiced we practiced a lot harder
uh back then than we do today
um and and i'm not i hope i don't just
sound like the old guy
you know saying oh things were tougher
back in the day it was just more of the
style you know you and and you had more
breaks
where you might have three games in four
days and then you'd have
three days off so you'd get two really
good days of practice
today it's pretty much game day off game
day off and and
most of our practices are you know
really uh pretty light
so back then you scrimmaged a lot and um
you know michael would go so hard in
those scrimmages he's just set a bar
that was incredibly high that everybody
had to live up to and it was one of the
reasons our team was prepared
you know every every year in the
playoffs because he set that tone every
single day
you think the nba and we have one more
minute with steve kerr before he goes
back out to blow the whistle
is the nba better or worse for the
change in the
in the aggressivity of those practices
uh boy that's a good question um i i do
think we
i know every coach feels great about
getting a couple of days of practice in
um
but the trade-off is that
you know the league has figured out
along with the players
uh over the last few years that uh you
know playing
playing six games in nine days is not
healthy and that's what we used to do
and and that's what gave us the practice
days because then you'd have this three
or four day break
you know so you take a day off and you
have like two great practices
those great practices were really
beneficial back in the day and i i
i would love to have that with our team
i think you can make really big strides
you know with great practices during the
middle of the season but
the league has done a great job of you
know not
stacking these games together and having
the players health in mind
and so that's why we our schedule is so
different and now we pretty much just
play every other day
and it's much healthier it's uh coaches
miss the practice time
but um we're also getting our our star
players who are
accumulating all those minutes we're
getting them more rest in between games
and not stacking up those back to back
so
it's just uh the compromise that we're
dealing with
steve kerr thank you so much for taking
the time to join us and know your
in-between
meetings and the like but it means a lot
for you to do so so thank you again for
your time
susie great to talk to you say hi to
rich and uh yeah we'll stay in touch i
don't think you have you been on the
show with rich before
i don't think so yeah good let's keep it
that way
he he sharked me years ago and i don't i
don't know what
what i did to make him mad oh no he's
just jealous he's just jealous that i
have your number
no no no no no no no this is uh this is
all about me one-upping him in the book
steve thanks again for your time we'll
talk soon all right
see you later bye the great steve kerr
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here